should we just draw dicks I love drawing
dicks I draw that that the dick part and
you draw the balls how about that okay
hey let's get prepared then this game is
the coop game yep
oh there oh I didn't see where you were
going really oh no I guess I don't see
your dick it off
that's a horrible dick no what do you
want from me okay that's a pretty good
dick there you go
it's a Christmas dick it's like a
strawberry a Christmas dick Christmas
dick
okay well before we go too crazy
welcome whoa okay so welcome to every
nom mmm I'm here with syrup all right
this is in your game for PlayStation 3
it's it's I don't know that much about
it like you you just kill people I
murdered that guy how that's good cuz he
was different from us okay I got this no
no yeah kill everyone that we don't kill
him we could have if we wanted to say me
cry
saying that huh I did it for you ah
thanks you don't worry about it
oh isn't this cute yeah hey hi hi hi hi
Oh up there yes
yep up there you want to go up there yes
hi thanks bro yep I do it again always a
trooper oh oh I got you got this [ __ ]
okay go up just okay go ahead save me
cry
same no problem thank you
okay I'll go top all right open with
that
ah come on get up oh no crap that's our
4 you need the pun I don't know he think
there's not even poison boys this game
god damn you
yeah yeah
you die yeah go there have [ __ ] you did
it okay well it wasn't even difficult go
go yeah you million boy [ __ ] the boys
wait
yep it's killem no we want to play
soccer
oh okay let's play with this one all
right oh you mean call me you mean
football right screw your Swedish ways
screw your American hey that guy was our
friend
oh god yeah you're what happened our sir
I know that's what I did
oh look I just did can't do it oh [ __ ]
and see what you did do it again please
okay points oh my whoa oh [ __ ] oh go
back that's it hey go thanks get to it
here to die but cry buts cry it's your
shirt I said huh hey go buddy
but now I but what about
okay nailing it yep I got it
I love the alternate dimension thing I
guess you could call to mention like up
down there like yeah down Daisy oh then
they Oh down here okay and they're not a
big knot okay yeah man oh these guys are
talking about well I can f what we we
didn't get that many points crying oh
those are points yep now we're here
shamefully drying out another sad face
if the brown I'll draw the eyes that's
one night that's it looks like a frog it
kind of looks like nature looks like a
frog sauna okay and let's run over here
okay bye oh hey that's another car go to
the top it's my friend he laughed me
mourn
see how happy is oh I see yeah he's
already happy about things people
there's another friend girlfriend mom oh
well you're the worst person ever
hey I do my way what is this
no connection whoo
that's racist I know that's exactly what
it is
there you go
oh and then you gotta come in here and
then we can finally get up here with
your assistance
uh-huh I can't get over there ah well
that's just too [ __ ] bad in there
yeah okay fine thank you
no what is it ah okay I need to be out
fishing again
thank you you're welcome no problem
you're welcome
I don't need your assistance now maybe I
do take the points cry good points no
wait I got him I got him
I got some some point dose help me up
here whoa Oh God
a [ __ ] sorry we're doing pretty good I
think we're due I'm sure buddy the point
goddamnit
Oh what how did I die cuz when I die you
die er is vice versa
that's dramatic dafuq really it's it's
like Romeo and Juliet what I can't - I'm
sorry why do I die it will shed some guy
wha what
alright miss this is what I'm supposed
to kill one on one side alright vice
versa and then you get the other one on
the other side yeah but I click at the
points huh okay
my god okay now I got the points here
now I go here and then I get I don't
because oh we're good okay Oh crying
seriously focus geez okay all right damn
it alright we gotta go up here I'm
drawing if I can't go up there nice nice
that uh-huh okay so I gotta jump across
and what about oh yes of course you got
to go down there oh yes and I get those
points I in love those points thank you
for loving those points you are very
welcome
I gotta be in here now I guess okay jump
you just push me like ball
you know we're spawning on the spiked
balls points
oh sorry you missed every single one
it's what I do
okay wait I don't need you hey oh my
gosh okay
this beautiful game is being tarnished
well your inability to cooperate don't
worry about it
okay so alright you did it good job
you're welcome
want a medal yes alright know where it's
that way somewhere okay uh-huh I got I
got the bike ride up hey I think you're
right about there
no I'm not like right around that you're
oh oh now you're here no I'm not I did
it
Oh Oh what don't worry I got this I got
this - I got it check it out check it
out oh it's like portal but when uh what
else - short oh that's nice hey York
Erica chuckling that races is just
shortest if that I think No
well you should feel bad either way
dammit no no okay we're good dude
there's like a giant wheel behind that
Bush wait wait it's all right
wait over here ah yes oh yeah we died
the same time wait did you die I die you
die okay I died yeah okay I go too early
it seems wait wait cry before you do
something stupid
what no this won't nothing ending okay
okay you can't see me now
all right hey Scott - ha ha ha
Oh uh-oh good job thanks I didn't notice
this blue guy don't die please yeah I
will good get the point get those boys
you think it's fine get the poor huh
wait I got it oh good yeah darn it
don't worry about it I know exactly huh
hi like I can't get off there's a
football back right that's a football I
am over the drawing is not gonna help
you just come here general directions
rings oh man I'll bring the football
okay take it okay
oh there's another yeah you got there oh
I did how can I don't go over there
oh no I'm so confused I don't know man
just look at that [ __ ] Wow look at it
Thanks
you're welcome good wait wait a second I
don't know oh wait I know I know what do
you know jump on me
there we go Becca welcome
I got Dow it
I'm so sorry